[Music]
this one's going to take a little bit of
a imagination so close your eyes and
just picture this exact mental image
cookies you're in ireland
you're a construction worker mm-hmm
you work at the top of a crane
i'm out what's up with the crane
okay oh okay here's that
it's a long long way down so you can't
be bothered to go and just take a piss
or take a [ __ ] or anything you just have
to
find the nearest plastic bag to [ __ ] in
wow
i got one of those things
no you're in a residential you're in a
residential area in a crane yeah you're
in a crane i'm like trimming some hedges
or something there's a 7-11 across the
street can i get a monster real quick
you can't do it you won't even go down
there it takes too long okay the crane's
real high up so you're on top of this
crane you've just finished filling an
entire plastic bag with your own [ __ ] oh
god good aim what do you do with it you
don't want this bag of [ __ ] up there
with you i chuck it in yes that's
exactly oh my god that's exactly what
happens so you chuck that big old bag of
[ __ ] down and it lands on the roof of
some guy's house
that's exactly what this dude did who's
who's whose house he got in trouble for
it who's awesome here we go it's it's
actually on video oh god the chucking is
on video all of it's outfitted shut the
[ __ ] it's full recording but it's a
tick-tock thing it's his [ __ ] laugh
that's hilarious i [ __ ] hate she's
irish here you go let's see if you
visualized it correctly uh joey's
abandoned driver
that's a big-ass [ __ ]
and uh
this guy sounds like conor mcgregor
it's pretty funny
[Laughter]
gosh it exploded
damn
yeah so this guy got fired from his
construction job that was a big lock
how did he get caught
dumb ass and posted this [ __ ] on
tick-tock yeah tick-tock
yeah he's an idiot thanks that is the
[ __ ] funniest thing to get fired for
i think that's
it's really funny i don't i think it
should be frowned upon but i feel like
uh that's really funny though do you
feel like it's like getting fired from
the job is like getting fired on that
contract but then still being hired as a
contractor maybe you know for other
projects or is it like you are no longer
working in this industry it's probably
for that company you know what's crazy
like so when he got fired he was pissed
at the person that ratted him out
whenever that happens
that's the best dude
i'm not wrong i bet you that's because
everyone does it and he's just the first
one to get oh
everyone's [ __ ] maybe everybody did it
for like a century but then they didn't
have tick tock at the time because you
know those crane workers really do like
they don't go down to [ __ ] or piss they
just
go in something yeah it's not convenient
you can't be the [ __ ] pioneer of
throwing a bag of [ __ ] off a crane can
you imagine working with people that you
guys seem [ __ ] all the time and
stuff be interesting
if i saw like bark well that'd be that
wouldn't be weird but seeing everybody
else in this room [ __ ]
you know uh bart's like naked all the
time in here
but you're like naked all the time so if
you did take a [ __ ] you're only like one
degree away from normal it's not as
crazy it doesn't look any different yeah
but that's one's like a vulnerable
position i'm making emotional faces this
is weird it's emotional it's emotional
time but if we catch bart in the parking
lot doing a squat and scratching his
back with a [ __ ] tree branch it's not
even blinking we're just like
yeah but he's hot he's hot he's on his
head
have you guys been through a childhood
phase of pooping in places you're not
supposed to no okay i didn't have the
courage
i thought it wasn't
nobody has okay i didn't have the balls
to do that yeah
my friend's a pediatrician they say that
doesn't happen actually and it's super
weird there was a abandoned house
and my friend thought it was so funny to
like break into their house
and then poop in their toilet right and
his brother thought it was so funny to
do it
like in their backyard
and i thought it was conflicting
opinions yeah to climb up on the roof
and take a [ __ ] inside the chimney
that's the creature
everybody that's actually pretty funny
though hey you win
9th grade the official submission for
the streaming the first
like
taking a [ __ ] in a chimney that's next
level dude no like on the top yeah i
know i know that's the magic i sat on it
like a toilet and took a dump inside and
my friend climbed up to make sure i
would do it and he was laughing the
whole time oh so you really did it and i
was laughing so hard that this [ __ ] came
out like that honestly though
that's pretty legendary yeah and hey
you're joe mama i ran up there with them
i roll a toilet paper that's how you
brought the toilet paper up yeah oh nice
did you put the toilet paper down the
chimney too i don't know about the
toilet paper just to tp the other house
didn't even use it see that's not that's
not really as crazy you actually like
cleaned yourself up but you know like
those guys that are really like nuts and
they'll just [ __ ] and then pull their
pants up and they'll just laugh and you
can't [ __ ] do that you're missing an
itchy elephant
no [ __ ] well you're talking about the
people that can downtown that [ __ ] on
the stuff no i mean just like just like
rowdy ass dudes i don't know people are
rowdy and rowdy no but like they'll just
be like check this out and they'll just
[ __ ] on the street like college football
exactly as a joke but then if if they
actually have toilet paper cleaners up
i'm like that's still civilized yeah
yeah yeah but i get scared by the dudes
that just [ __ ] and pull their pants off
yeah there's something dark about that
yeah exactly there's something dystopian
about it
yeah cause i never
i never understood that like i always
think about that after i take a [ __ ]
right i'm like what did the ancients do
before toilet banana leaves
well i mean like just in general like if
you're in the jungle right you just take
a dump and then you stand right back up
are they so organic and healthy that
they have those magical poops where like
you just don't need a wipe because you
know sometimes that has a little ghost
we didn't have that much stool like the
way the dog dogs do it right yeah
i mean they licked their ass to clean it
but they probably just jumped in the
nile river and then like rinsed under
and oh yeah probably that could be i had
a college roommate that was like that i
came home once and then the door was
you're just [ __ ] and the door was
just open and i'm like
you didn't close the door
and he's like oh okay you don't like it
and then he closed it i was just like
damn this guy's like you're not my wife
okay i want my wife to have the door
open okay you don't like it no he would
just say hi he'll be like oh hey guys
just taking a [ __ ] no lie that was
lawrence kyle i hate to blast him on
such a private thing but
but when is it i do picture him because
lauren's kyle reminds me of him because
that guy also doesn't wear underwear on
the regular didn't wear underwear
he would shower with the door open or
unlocked and then he never used the
towel he air dries so he would like wear
underwear put his jeans back on imagine
that feeling like you're still wet i'm
not gonna tell he's just such a [ __ ]
rebel i'm not gonna wear underwear and
put my jeans on and go wet and when i
say [ __ ] the door can be open lauren
says charming enough guys who say like
not air dry
those are rebels dude they're renegades
yeah they're like they're like future
leaders keep an eye on those guys have
you guys tried that like getting out of
the shower just putting on clothes i've
had to do it yeah sometimes out of
necessity it's not comfortable yeah
that's what i'm saying it's not
comfortable right it feels like you just
got drenched on a rainy day but your
clothes are dry but you're wet inside
and you hope you warm them up enough
it's a little weird you never asked
lauren's like why don't you just towel
off a little bit he's a rebel man what's
he going to say are you going to give me
logic
he's going to say isa pisa i sort of
know what he wants he's like you can't
cage a bird or it dies
do you guys ever like uh when your
significant others aren't home do you
guys ever walk around the house naked
never yeah or why why don't you how come
they aren't home like when they're at
work or something why can't you do that
when they are home you can but i just
feel like you're you feel like a baby
you're trying to respect your wife and
not show her do you feel like when
you're alone you should put clothes on
and be respectable and then when she's
here you should take them off no i think
the opposite i think like do you guys
have cameras in your house now no yeah
because i have cameras in my house now
so i think about that the whole time
like if a hacker can see me now
i'm just naked whatever the [ __ ] i want
yeah i honestly don't mind a hacker
hacking my [ __ ] and just seeing my naked
like i think that's worse for them yeah
good for them
you know what it is he'll make him give
up the
life one of the bathrooms my window it's
like kind of low so if i'm peeing
the my other neighbor if they're walking
upstairs they could see my dick peeing
into the toilet oh the upstairs that
kind of makes you feel powerful no it's
weird because one time i was peeing
and then [ __ ] i think they're getting
like i don't know the cabinet's redone
or some [ __ ] four [ __ ] construction
guys
just popped out of nowhere and i felt
shy so i was like peeing like this and i
was like whoa i don't have to like pee
like this on the wall but i still didn't
want to like get out yeah
one of my neighbors was just you know we
were just talking to her and stuff and
she was like i always wonder can you
guys see me if i'm naked or whatever and
we're like no i'm like you want to come
upstairs and see for yourself and she's
like yeah can i oh my god so she goes up
to her room and she's like looking into
her house from our place and she's like
oh yeah you can't see [ __ ] and i'm like
yeah those are people who want to get
caught oh you think so absolutely oh
shannon pick up on that because there's
times where like
all right i'm gonna be very vulnerable
right now i like it should i okay time
to attack patreon patreon
okay
we do need to don't attack no if if uh
because my my bathroom also for some
reason it has like a floor to ceiling uh
window but obviously the [ __ ] blinds
are always down because it's a bathroom
right like you when you shower it's
smart however so obviously it's always
down especially because anybody who's in
my building or is close that can see it
from the elevator shaft or whatever
i don't want them seeing anything
but
wait so i turn the blinds in such a way
where nobody can see from close
proximity but from far away across the
street there's a whole other building
that can see through the blinds if i
turn it that way to block everybody else
but i have no problem with somebody
who's super far away seeing my ass okay
yeah because they don't know they don't
know who you are exactly right in my
building i'm like [ __ ] no dude that's
really weird it's like 240. from far
away i'm like
i don't care if you see me naked i think
you should show your ass boy you know
what i mean i gotta show last night i
was pounding on my wife pretty good and
the wind and like the windows are open
we don't have anything over them yet
like on the second story so i was like
pounding her pretty good and i was like
you know what if you could see this
you're kind of proud [ __ ] welcome
yeah right
there's there's some there's something
really weird about like if you're
perverted enough to try and pay
attention do you have a [ __ ]
kaleidoscope or whatever the [ __ ] that
you look like kaleidoscope
if you have a kaleidoscope
a hundred of you if you have a
kaleidoscope you probably shouldn't use
it to watch this but just so you know
[Music]
you